[Music]
things
that shouldn't exist this exists
delete this right now right now welcome
everyone
to lawyer the greatest show on the
goddamn planet you got any proof
otherwise
yeah i don't think so okay leave your
memes on the reddit 19 year old
now measure your peeps
[Music]
the collab we wanted pewdiepie and ksi
where we both go
the collab we are getting pewds telecase
item by
the flute case i tell pewdiepie i bought
them
he bought the float that's awesome but
did he buy the outpouring
last video i told kids i he needs to buy
an alphone
unless he's a goddamn beta come on ksi
what are you a
coward get an outboard
this could be you man this could be us
i'll buy one too [ __ ] it let's go to the
[Music]
we're gonna have to find out i hope you
bought it romanian lo-fi girl
oh is this a new meme template greek
lo-fi girl finnish lo-fi girl
hungarian lo-fi girl swedish lo-fi hey
it's the girl maya because my swedish
ever kind of cool to have one animated
for
different reasons kind of like that
where japanese anime girl huh
cat girl lo-fi girl i've been watching
baker monogatari let's just say i'm in
cat girls i mean since sims on reddit
upload anything here's a picture of
marzia
you did not upload this you didn't know
what i've never been this disappointed
it's still
no september i have not failed so far
i have not failed i've been doing my
part no problem
and this is how you repay me
disgusting nobody pewdiepie in about
five years
i wish i shaved by accident so annoying
hey by the way huge announcement if you
guys are a member on the pewdiepie
channel
we are now building a custom pewdiepie
gundam pretty epic he doesn't have any
legs
just like me that's hilar all right
we're building his legs still they're
coming along
it's going to be epic it's pretty fun
check it out ever
the amount of comments i've been getting
like what's wrong with his fingers
yeah it's paint i had to it's custom
build all right
it's going to look sick it's going to go
there instead of that ugly one it's
gonna
yeah become members would say yeah hi i
don't have money to donate or be a
member to type in pewds chat but it's
important to tell him that playing among
us yeah i saw this thank you very much
legit
apparently the game uses peer-to-peer so
they could actually get my ip address
and flip me over big time thank you
thank you for once you're helpful
how about that
for once now i appreciate it thank you
that was actually a legit concern
it's speaking of unhelpful help your
head goes in wrong position this could
damage to it i
do you think i care if my edgar gets
damaged no i don't
you could die for all like oh that's too
harsh but it is true all right when we
say it a lie
all right delete this the hell happened
to bel delphine she looks different now
a little hotter not gonna lie though not
100 sure what i made okay so i mentioned
that i like
3d animations like this one
all right i'll be real with you guys
you're always so real with me
if you don't like a video i'm the first
to hear about it
okay i don't i don't like it what look
at this
dude i have this you're trying to tell
me you made something better
i don't think so dude i have this
all right i appreciate the effort but
try again all right you got some talent
there make use of it dudes i'd freak
that guy
jack as if you haven't already hey roger
smith
oh sorry uh how do i record video guys
images you can hear
right there what game should we would
you like to see stream next
spongebob squarepants battle for bikini
bottom oh here we go
here we go guys so that was a freaking
lie yeah no
did i say i'm going to stream it no i
didn't i asked you guys and i
realized you guys have the wrong opinion
congratulations
marcia shellberg might see a pie might
see it oh
no oh no oh no
good meme very good meme do you think i
can wear tambourines on my legs
oh my god tambourine shoes is real
tambourine shoes all right i want them
stealth minus 75
rhythm plus 100 yeah all right
nice fifty percent concentrated power of
will
plus two hundred angry margin noises
plus five plus
what plus hundred percent peep increase
fifty percent
pain height all right you guys are funny
sometimes congratulations
what do you want an applause a platypus
perry the platinum
no no all right all right
it grew back it doesn't look like pair
of the platypus anymore
tell me what it looks like now i don't
even know people for those who are new
people have been seeing the future
in my beard and my beardy patches it's a
thing
all right this is cool all right oh
oh yeah
infinity browser i like it
now this real talent other one bad
wait you said less upvotes that's crazy
big people to this one where's my
tambourine
i can't find it feeling so much of being
cute yeah i'm surprised there wasn't
more memes about this
and the fact that i uploaded an entire
video uh that wasn't focused
has anyone ever done that
mercy was like it's okay we can reshoot
it nah
we don't reshoot on this channel might
see we don't do that the camera focusing
on itself through the mirror i swear to
god i focused on marzia
i don't know how it happened but it did
but i hope the video was enjoyable
anyway i thought it was fun oh yeah i
love this me
[Laughter]
well good meme good meme big beeping
large
it's huge yo no you ain't no champion
all right
i'm the goddamn champion know your god
damn please oh no what have i done
please
this means war okay you don't mess with
the pp champion
this means war i'm going to die
all right let's see what we got what do
you got tambourine
you've won me every man no
no tambourine king understand
[Music]
don't ever try to challenge me
hey all right let's see it
could be photoshopped not impressed
[Music]
oh
this battle is one in the name of this
game
[Music]
credit to roman goddard uh who made the
background
what do you mean made the background i
made that [ __ ] background where you
credited them
all right victory for tape gang i don't
really want to buy more tambourines but
i guess i have to defend my honor oh
other couples haha this picture i took
is funny
no delete it i look bad felix and
martial this will be memed on reddit
i know see that's chad
still a cute photo come on good memes
this week guys
all right air water earth pasta
yo no this is not original is it
oh yeah this is from thinking top of
gurren lagann hell yeah
that's sick dude now that's the
tambourine tower
to the moon to the moon i don't know if
it's still good but tangent top i
guarantee check it out it's
great he's got the glasses kind of
pewdiepie
yes i'm a 30 year old man building toys
you got
problem it's gonna be sick i'm quite
proud of it so yeah check out members
man
uh enters while pewds is recording pewds
get out that girl
you're disrupting my recording edgar
leaves pewds
wait no come back i didn't
i didn't do that hey edgar
i need cute views but yeah check your
whatsapp
what does she say accurate
she controls the pasta well done guys me
with no awards to give
someone with genuine good but has 16
uploads
really good stuff bro see you in the y
big peepee
oh that's cool that's wholesome see in
the way
where all the memes go to die pewds said
he likes seamless animation i did
yeah they're bouncing in and out ooh i
like
i like it like yes yes yes ew
what is this felix need to show it to
marzia is that what our child would look
like
we're never having kids that's that's
imagine if we have a child and they grow
up and then they watch this video and
they look exactly like that
hey shed you [ __ ] ugly dude
and also disappointment hey if you don't
build gundams with me when i'm old
[ __ ] you [ __ ] marzia i'm sick i can't
go to school
how are you too sick to go to school but
not too sick to play video games
it's still a cute meme template i like
it you know what big peeping if i didn't
upload it last time i should've uploaded
this thing
ah that's so cute
edgar cam the newest favorite edition of
everyone on the
uh for everyone on this channel hey let
me
don't put your head in my crotch you gay
look cute
i need views dude you're [ __ ] fat
dude look at these rolls dude
i'm joking don't be sad excuse me
i'm still asking if we could get a
pewdiepie skin youtubes
please i'll do anything this is a great
time to mention
that we have pewdiepie figurines belted
myself guys pewdiepie that store check
it out
can we get a all right so we have edgar
cam can we get a g
fuel cam as well nice they get they
can't see you you're not cute enough
i know you're cute ah there it is
there's a headgear cam everyone loves
you tired of you yes
all right sick okay that's actually cool
big peepee been watching since high
school mad love from indonesia
thank you indonesia gang i like it what
the market player sees with
pewdiepie sees every day we stray
further from god
who made this and why stop it
okay you don't look uh you don't look
amazed by this video what's the problem
i woke him up sorry this is funny
looking at him falling asleep
so we're gonna fly this drone which has
a phone attached to it
which is playing pokemon go i can't
believe this is the same guy that failed
to make cobblestone generator
for three episodes true
that was a pretty fun video good times
yo
no that's sick
yes sorry you got to use this in the
next among us videos
oh it's live there oh that's so dumb
sorry i killed your side
sorry uh this coco melon and pewdiepie
fight drawing took me a few weeks to
draw damn
dope well done big pig beat to you
all right well this is why
why men with tambourine earring
oh that's kind of cute i do like it big
peepee to you
mice and matchsticks i
i can't say understand it
again what do you rate it you look so
dead inside that guy what's the secret
he's so tired look at it
am i waking you up am i annoying at
garrett
huh don't care this dog is okay beware
of the owner
the dog the own what a relevant meme huh
what do you think gengar what do you see
oh sorry did i scare you hey humongous
fan art oh that's sick
dude oh look edgar you're in this one
timothy andre won
big people to you i love it yes
hey hey hey hey
yeah yeah i am winning
yes get away every single card though
speak people gang to your main no
no side do not edit us being sweet oh
god damn inside
all right fine this is fine i actually
prefer it this way
hey damn oh
[Music]
i gotta get the comedy glasses r u2l
uh i don't know if i said this enough
but everyone making a video
like that's been so cool i i really owe
you guys
i really do uh actually i take that back
it was my cake day
and literally no one said anything
september 10.
no congratulations oh
oh i'm not mad or anything
i don't even care but yeah cool intro
thank you guys appreciate
all right so we got pewdiepie we got
pewdiepie
pud pie die pew pew pew pew pew
good me made me laugh sad fact this is
actually the last
video that opens up with house of golden
bros my name is pewdiepie
no no i don't believe that who named sir
cat bongo
one year later bongo cat memes what
that's more impressive yeah
[Laughter]
nice oh here we go
oh that's pretty dope there's no real
pewdiepie branding to it though
but i do like the texture your island
animal crossing is amazing
thanks who is your favorite villager do
you like clicky bro
yes yes i like it connectivity very much
i actually made like a bruh this morning
that's how much i like connected bruh
look my phone is dusty from connected
bra dust
that's how much connective bra fan i am
that's how much i look like a
i don't want to take pictures with fans
understandable have a great day thanks
for understanding
can i pet edgar and maya yeah a guy can
they pet you
what do you say partner can they pet you
you look so tiny and pathetic from here
look at you
you look so funny uh you're comfortable
only watching no
they have to see you i decide i pay for
your
dog food god damn it all right fine
you're too cute listen edgar harasses me
on a daily basis don't be like oh i feel
so bad for anger
he deserves this plus i i do love him
sometimes right anger
piercing his normal videos pins in his
videos
i understand the joke oh we gotta watch
doofenshmirtz
i mean finnish and firm on live streams
again become member we will i'll watch
it again all right
everyone loves got the florida bring it
back and that's the fact all right one
more time i'll do it
if this video gets a billion likes let's
get on it ready damn you guys delivered
on this [ __ ]
god damn all right that's cool i'll use
that
that's sick who made this stephen even
yeah we got the pewdiepie branding
yeah that's aesthetic it's all about
aesthetic guys what's the point of life
otherwise
legit downloading this one rtx off
rtx on goddamn all right a billion likes
guys and i'll play minecraft this week
but this has been
everything for now thank you for
watching thank you for all the memes
most importantly
i'm so proud of this community thank you
for uh
congratulating me on my cake day isn't
that right edgar
uh can you tell the video's ending edgar
is so dumb but he can tell him when the
video's ending
all right thanks for watching guys leave
a like look at him yeah
he knows smash like and subscribe and
uh bro face
oh the video is over that means we're
gonna play yes
yeah no no we're not
children of nine parts
it's time to raise what was once
forgotten
what creatures fox spells and poop
troops awaits
poopty is coming to
nintendo switch
and remember it has a very big pp
pre-order promotion i mean